let's get a better sense of hermas track
and potential threat Lonnie Quinn chief
weather caster from our New York station
WCBS is here with the latest
Lonnie good morning and good morning to
you and good morning everybody you know
we're Jeff Glor is located down there on
Biscayne Bay we just checked in on the
stats that they've already had one foot
that's not much but they've had one foot
of storm surge and this storm is miles
away let me give you the latest
information from the National Hurricane
Center this is the latest update that
just came in moments ago you're gonna
notice the wind speed has come down and
I can tell you why it came down it was
up at 155 miles per hour it's now down
to 130 mile per hour maximum wind that's
because it's interacting with the North
Shore of Cuba we've had a landfall that
wasn't anticipated a little wobble to
the south that's what these things do
okay they wobble they wobble back and
forth it is forecast though to continue
off to the northwest west-northwest at
12 miles per hour right now 225 miles
from Miami so we've got to get to the
track has the track changed well it
still sees that big turn to the north
very possible to see a landfall around
the Florida Keys as a cat 4 and again
right now at 130 miles per hour that's
barely a cat for 129 you're into a cat 3
but we believe the Florida Straits that
water is so warm it's gonna strengthen
it and then push it up into Florida
possibly staying offshore but you can't
rule that out of having a landfall the
entire state at risk because of the
entire width of this storm even the East
Coast will be affected alright Athens go
over to you our New York station wcbs-tv
thanks Lonnie